plus de 1300 armoires sont présents dans
le département elle raccorde les sept
cent mille foyers yvelinois au très haut
débit
certaines communes ont vu leurs réseaux
téléphoniques se moderniser nous avons
pour une quarantaine de communes dans
cette situation mis en oeuvre une
technologie intercalaires 1 pour un
certain temps en amenant finalement on
peut dire on a amené la fibre en un
point du village au niveau du réseau
téléphonique le département fait une
innovation et les premiers en france à
voir fait ça c'est plutôt que de monter
un système public nous avons fait
confiance à une entreprise qui s'appelle
délai f
l'entreprise est intervenu sur 149
commune dans la partie rurale du
département
un chantier à plus de 100 millions
d'euros qui dit ruralité dit beaucoup de
fibres a déployé beaucoup de travaux
beaucoup de personnes a mobilisé on
attirer 5000 km de câbles on a déposé
280 armoire de rue
deux autres opérateurs étaient présents
sur le chantier orange sfr engagé avec
l'état dès 2011 et 2013
l'enjeu principal était de tenir nos
engagements qu'on avait pris par rapport
au département en terme de géographie et
donc on a une centaine de communes sur
lequel on était déployé et puis en
termes de calendrier on a
après 77 milles prises fibre à déployer
aujourd'hui nous avons fait 94 95 % des
prises qui sont raccordables
on avait à l'origine que 62000 prise à
faire et puis la croissance
démographique et ans le nombre de
logements se sont multipliés un chantier
de trois ans dans les yvelines près de
95% des foyers sont aujourd'hui
raccordés ou éligibles au très haut
débit